I
huh you can hear me all right we got to
start with a selfie right of course
let's let's get everybody heads up
bouquets up like this hands up high yeah
one two three nice thank you guys I love
cool it's an honor to be here with you
guys today but a lot of people over the
last couple days and i love your mission
at eleven drove out today can talk about
how to develop it to the selfie
generation what I think about libraries
and when I asked my friends about
libraries a lot of times this is a
reaction people people are bored people
don't think libraries are relevant
libraries are not part of the daily
fabric like they used to be I think
that's kind of sad I think that's kind
of sad considering how important
historically libraries have been and how
you guys have reached you know hundreds
of millions of people ont my flickr that
flag I want you to be great I was
looking up famous libraries on Google
when I was at home preparing this
presentation and the one-line way that
kept coming up over and over and over
and over man was the Great Library of
Alexandria and I agree it's a great
library I think could learn a lot from
their success spell touching them alive
in his presentation but everyone you
guys to be great I found it kind of sad
that there was no other library that was
consistently referred to as a great
library as a
library and my goal for you guys is that
in a thousand years people are still
talking about how great a library you
built I want your library to stand the
test of time and then model for other
libraries look up to and so hopefully
I'll give me some of the tools today do
the help you do that but first one to
tell you a story this is me when I was
in grade school I had a lot more hair
and this is my librarian mrs. Donnelly
and any time I had a problem anytime I
was researching a project i would go to
mrs. Donnelly and she would give me the
knowledge that I needed to finish my
project right I would walk into this
library and get thousands of books I
didn't know where to start and I'm
talking mrs. darling she would guide me
to the knowledge that I needed I was
like on the High School in carter came
around I'm carly was the big thing you
guys remember micarta and when I first
heard about a card about mrs. darling
and I would go in with a problem mrs.
darling load up in Carter help me find
the knowledge that I needed when I
graduated internet camera and then went
to mrs. Donnelly she didn't know how to
use the internet and that was a problem
because not my sources of knowledge
expanded infinitely almost and I didn't
have a guy to help me so because it only
didn't know how to use the internet I
had to figure it out for myself and this
is where mrs. Donnelly the librarians
role started to lose relevance and value
these are sad sack you probably know but
a lot of the knowledge search now starts
with a search engine right eighty
percent of new searches start from high
school students are sorry for teenagers
with a google search and less than 1%
start on the library's website and as a
result libraries and any funding cuts
nobody's this is American data I'm
assuming that the
for you guys are at but 23 States
recently cut budget in the United States
and another forty percent are expecting
more cuts and the challenge is as
libraries have been so attached the
books and how they haven't kept up
enough with the growth of knowledge they
become less relevant and because you're
less relevant we're not getting as much
funding as we're before and Michael I
want to I want to change this is gone as
far as some people expecting libraries
to be extinct people are predicting that
in 10 to 20 years it won't be a library
anymore and I think that's really sad
but I'm optimistic I think there's a
bright bright future for libraries we
just have to figure out how to keep calm
and stay relevant and I need the tools
hoping today to help you do that for me
it starts with thinking about what a
library is and I also back to the origin
because words to me are important and if
you look at the definition of library it
always comes back into the Blue Origin
it always was back to books somehow in
whatever language at least that I saw
I've always relates the book somehow and
that's a problem because libraries not
just about folks and an old on you get
that and you're making changes but the
changes are happening fast enough to not
radical enough and as long as we hitch
our wagon to books then you may end up
going extinct I would redefine it as a
house of knowledge libraries are house
involved and I would love for library we
saw all this you can change their name
recognizing that the word itself relates
the books and we are not just about
anymore we're a house acknowledging in
the past books were knowledge that's how
we got our knowledge and as we've
evolved the longer you tie yourself just
the books then the less problem that
we're going to be because our knowledge
scape is increasing and books will
always be a part of it there will always
be a part of it but it's not able to
party tomorrow so I'm going to assume
now that we're on board with this
mission of being a house of knowledge
and that changes decisions that you make
it changes how you opportunity I
concentr teeny the changes strategy for
your organization I gave you five ways
to stay more relevant as a house of
knowledge instead of a house of books so
if I my house acknowledge what i want to
do the first thing i want to do is
provide access to the knowledge and
library external it'd be great day they
had both committed by baptist and
knowledge now it all is on line one
provide access online and most lenders
have internet it gets pretty basic now
is Wi-Fi but it's not great Wi-Fi it's
not great internet you know if I had to
come to a city and I really needed to
get online for a presentation or to
learn something my first choice wouldn't
be a library how good a starbucks i
would go to mcdonalds at least from the
library's an eye pin to mcdonalds and
starbucks have faster Wi-Fi mcdonalds
and starbucks give me faster access to
knowledge then the house of knowledge
why can't libraries have the fastest
internet in the city if I was running a
librarian helping one of my top
priorities the fastest internet anywhere
in the city is at a library come get
rapid access to the knowledge that
you're looking for nexus guide them to
know so we're house of knowledge we need
to guide and go to the knowledge just
like mrs. Donnelly got any technology
when I was in school and I think as our
have expanded the need for a god has
only grown more important right when I
went into library there's only a
thousand books now there's billions of
pieces of information out there and the
librarian helps provide the context so
we need guides more than ever to all the
library the library is only growing in
importance because people have
information overload we need knowledge
means to help us guide us to the
knowledge but you have to have the
context you have to know that knowledge
to really take me to the knowledge I
think that's part challenges a lot of
librarians now don't have the relevant
knowledge anymore to keep me up to date
it's also expanded the definition of
what knowledge is and what services we
offer as libraries this is a picture
from a trauma library where they
installed a green screen room two people
to come in and fill videos I know if you
guys like green screens or know some of
your slowly changing and evolving some
lockers after 3d printing and a part of
the maker movement right some libraries
allow you to take that musical
instruments allow you to take out of
technology to loan let's expand our
definition right now the right house of
knowledge miles of books what is
knowledge and system and how can we be a
resource to the people in our community
number three is you want to bring it
with us when I go to a Starbucks what
Starbucks life that I just finish this
batteries you going to stomachs in any
city what do you see I miss it this
event is a starbucks just down the road
here I grab the cappuccino what do you
see you see people study right you see
people starting you see people working
you see people learning why are they not
in a library why are they here and part
of it is because suburbs creates a great
environment right somebody says music
starbucks sells you coffee sells you
food gives you a place to work lets you
plug in i think this is a missed
opportunity for a lot of libraries
because i know it's just changing for a
lot of libraries now but to slowly is
still the perception that in the library
where does it say that to learn it has
to be quiet how much learnings do guys
done here today talking to each other in
rooms over dinner last night not much
happens from connecting with people and
yes there's definitely in place for
quiet independent study that will never
go away but the opportunity to connect
with others and the reason why people
are going to starbucks is because they
want that environment why can't you play
music in part of the library why can't
you sell food and some coffee and get
people environment that they wanted
working like starbucks is how do their
business models created in my opinion
because libraries couldn't keep up this
could be your business how much billions
of dollars at starbucks make while
you're worried about funding cuts this
could be an opportunity to revive the
library and make it a home people want
to come to TED Talks another example oh
and just back sorry on my morning this
fine the great variability Andrea used
to have shared dining rooms because they
understood that people learn when they
connect with each other and they learn
while they're eating and somewhere along
the lines we decided that that's not
cool that doesn't take place in the
library but the model is there just in
love with the greatest library of all
time tedtalks the letter Gonzaga are
also used to have people come in and
speak at the library and they would pay
a stipend for this
Karen's family to come and educate the
people who are attending at the library
and that needs to exist but it's no
longer happening at libraries it's
happening at conferences like Ted why is
Ted not happening at libraries why are
you not partnering with Ted and have
people come to your institution
warehouses knowledge why are people
going elsewhere to get their knowledge
though gates comes up on Ted his talk
was an education why is not in the
library he's talking about education so
it's another model where there is need
right the need for knowledge is not
going away but other businesses have
been created because the libraries have
kept up and and haven't been the house
of knowledge that we need other examples
book tours people go on book tours when
they're launching the books big-name
celebrities this is hillary clinton on
her book tour again i don't even make
stops at libraries maybe some but for
the most part it's not my book source
why can't you stop off at libraries
you're gonna have her book and you
receive all the bookstores they sell the
books why can't you sell books of
libraries maybe that's a radical
business model maybe you're not
permitted for some reason but I
understand people want to lend out the
books but why can't you also buy the
books again it's another business model
that's been created because the library
is nothing have done so you look at
internet cafes you look at starbucks you
look at bookstores you look at Ted and
conferences all of these multi-billion
dollar businesses have been created
around knowledge meanwhile libraries are
being cut with budget and funding
there's a lot of opportunities and the
need for knowledge is not going anywhere
is if anything only more important the
libraries have to play
roll in last week's pretty people to do
around the vents I think disease if I do
a better job than libraries of this
where these events being hell do you
want to bring people in right you want
to show up your space even this like
today we're a bunch of librarians why is
this not being held in the library right
why I maybe libraries aren't set up for
this but why not why can't we be set up
for this right we are a host of
knowledge we're full of librarians here
and we're not learning in a library I
want to have a space that I'm proud of
hosting events bringing in thought
leaders and being a house of knowledge
so taking that shift from just being
about books to radically change anything
about knowledge impacts a lot of
decisions that you make as an
organization number fours go to them as
a hosted knowledge miner who check and
he part of the community so here's an
example with out of the UK with move out
libraries and the knowing all of you or
some of you already have some of these
initiatives happening and it's a great
idea to reach out in the community this
is a trench hanging off North America I
don't know if it's happening here or
maybe you guys started it but people are
taking a poll and put it in the front
lawn and building a box and inside
they're putting books you guys have this
yes okay there's a sign on it that says
take a book legal book why is it not
being led by libraries how many of you
guys actually a part of this movement
couple hands I love it why can't I go to
a lacquer effectively this is you know
in my neighborhood our library has
nothing to do with these and they should
like teaching people how to build these
things give them the map to that and
then go to a local hardware store and
buy the tools to make it on your website
promote links to where people can go
like give them a map of all the
different places that have these things
right this is the most Freddy knowledge
you should love this this should be a
part of your model the fact that people
are doing things like this and that
you're not involved shows that there is
is need and the trend is already started
you don't have to leave the trend just
being part of them wherever people are
that's where you want to be wherever
there's a group of people that's where
you want to be providing knowledge this
is a big rock concert happening you know
Bruce Springsteen is coming to town why
is there not a pop-up library they're
giving you knowledge about Bruce spring
Springs me in the history of rock and
roll there's a big football match I
didn't say soccer there's the same
soccer it's good big football match
Madrid Barcelona is playing why is he
going to pop up library at the stadium
with the history of football and how
real madrid came to be right where the
people are that's where you want to be
as a library we're talking about selfies
cell degeneration you need to know about
trending knowledge you want to be
leading that front and providing
resources people want to learn how to
take selfies give them knowledge on how
to take selfies teach people how to take
a picture have resources around
photography or link out to video people
can learn Will Smith one of the defining
actors of this generation loves reading
when he won an award he went up on stage
and said the keys of life two teenagers
he's the life are running and reading
and reading because any poem that you
have has already dissolved it's in a
book somewhere whatever problem you have
even like somebody has figured it out
and wrote a book about it so go read
then he go to the oprah winfrey show and
it brings his kids he's talked about
breeding and his finger work for his
kids is rich dad poor that he could go
on Oprah and talk about anything talk
about his movie promote something that
has coming up he chose to go on and talk
about reading this is somebody that
today's generation looks up to how many
libraries then create an exhibit around
Will Smith where they're sharing that
video clip where I can walk in and see
the rich dad poor dad series are you
sharing in
website on social media right we've got
somebody who's looked up to as an icon
by this generation dr. jump on board to
help you in your cause when new movies
come out when the elections are
happening when sports teams are facing
off against each other you want to have
relevant trending knowledge this is why
people think libraries are boring
because you're not part of trending
conversations so Star Wars comes up when
I walk into your library do I see Star
Wars display other other books in links
to videos and resources about Star Wars
and science fiction books in astronomy
and astrology as some of you may be
doing and that's amazing all you should
be doing it this is this is the basis of
handed having trending knowledge so
since is not with social media we have
to again because social media is from
use awareness the child should mean when
they look at libraries is you everybody
month on you first because you could
have all the greatest Twitter strategies
in the world but if you're not providing
value then the awareness isn't helpful
so the 90s I don't want you to find
access to knowledge guide them
technology bring it all to them go to
them so I bring people into you go to
them and be a part of trending
conversations now we can hit up
awareness so where it is 101
introduction to awareness is wherever
your clients are ever your market is
that's what you want to be so I was
selling two redheaded women wherever
this is I want to be right so if you're
selling to the 13 17 year olds or 17 and
35 year olds whatever you're on
whoever they are that's where you need
to be that's marketing and awareness 101
so where is today's generation 31 online
you probably seen the figures this is
the most recent one teenagers were
spending 11.3 hours on YouTube per week
versus 8.3 on TV youtube they feel good
about watching the phils relevant to
them and those numbers are only getting
worse those numbers are always doing
more and more and more online so as a
library targets that generation that's
where you need to be as well here are
five people I don't know how many people
all five of these people Smosh fine
brothers cutie pie Ryan case I you know
all five of these people tell me what
they do have you seen them the names
familiar no now this is American data so
it's a little skewed but the top five
celebrities for teens are youtubers
these five people are youtubers and the
whole team is a group who the celebrity
you like it was your favorite summary
right now and the top five are youtubers
they're not singers the not musicians
they're not actors and our athletes
there youtubers further down the list
Paul Walker's and actor Jennifer
Lawrence under games actress Katy Perry
international singer but the top five
are all youtubers and the fact that you
wouldn't know who the youtubers our show
is kind of a lack of knowledge right
because these people can be great
resources for you and this is where the
lack of respect might come in towards
librarians where somebody coming in and
people that they look up to and you have
no idea who they are that creates a
problem there's a disconnect they're
going to feel like well this person
can't help guide to the knowledge they
don't know what I'm talking about if
we're the business of knowledge and you
need to market and get the attention of
the youth they have to know what they
care about and a great way to model that
is look at other businesses right I love
them all and success you know the
answers are already there we talked
about the bootlegger valid am your ally
look at a company that does well
marketing and connecting with you you
look at a company like coca-cola there's
always trying to target the next young
generation you talk to people at
coca-cola they would know but these
people are they will be China
correlations with these people to get
the awareness out and so that's going to
be your business if that's the energy
that your reign is connecting with young
people then you have to know these
people too and you have to know the
things that your audience cares about
because until you do they just see you
as a history resource and that's not
relevant as much anymore only having a
color the knowledge isn't great for
organization that's supposed to be the
house of knowledge you guys know who has
a notices anybody knows into those
anyway
Xena notice was the first head librarian
the Great Library on center and I
struggled to find who are great
libraries nobody came up you know our
kids graduating high school and universe
is saying i wanted to be a library I
think they should be you need to give
them a reason to me it's staying at me
crowd a good profession and this guy was
the greatest librarian of all time and
one thing understand about David Otis
was that he wasn't just a manager yes he
meant a big ladder he was a thought
leader he was an expert he was a writer
he was a speaker he shared his powerful
opinions he was the first editor of
Homer and he was editor for a bunch of
other epic poets when was the last time
you saw a great book being in a written
or edited by a librarian maybe they
exist but I couldn't find it I think
that's that I think for the directors in
this room this is your job it's not just
about managing an organization you need
to be a thought leader you have
knowledge and opinions that can guide
people that can make changes to the city
that you're in and that's your
responsibility to stand up and let your
voice be heard and if we could find what
a library basically and also
acknowledged in the house of knowledge
needs a leader needs to leave to a
contar con College and share that
knowledge and inspire others at the
Great Library of Alexandria the other
people who worked at the library besides
Xena notice they were in charge of
transcribing all the scrolls right a
scroll came in and they need to make a
thousand copies of it they were
providing them access to more people
that was a job with the people work with
the library and
relevant today what you need to do is
provide access in a way that today's
generation understand because they're
not going in and reading 500 pages of a
book so your job is to translate the tax
into things that they can understand
transy to the Facebook and Twitter and
YouTube Instagram and snapchat and if
something new comes up you two you're
putting on this YouTube to that should
be the job of the house of knowledge so
here's somebody to do it you can got
gambling you're looking to put it on
Facebook so on facebook we would have a
picture and then we wouldn't have you'll
make it relevant so tiny to current
events maybe there's something from
hamline that can be relevant to the US
presidential election right now Tigers
toys together give me a long-form
content give me five points of what
lessons Donald Trump could learn from
handling and share now we're posting
valuable content does most people what
they quoted on Facebook is that putting
their hours of operation or they'll put
in work clothes tomorrow right social
conversations are about conversations
it's about something that people would
want to share as anybody going to share
that your library is closed tomorrow is
anybody going to go talk to the friend
it's not going to happen but lessons
that Donald Trump could learn to handle
it now your sparkling conversation so
the stuff that you post on social you
want it to spark conversation it's just
in micro formats twitter is even shorter
Twitter give a limited number of
characters it's usually has some kind of
link that you
flu so quick headline and a link off to
somewhere else youtube for making videos
so i would love to see you guys as
directors coming up to share your
opinions on the election tell me
something that I can learn from you are
a thought leader you're shaping the
fabric of this city for decades to come
embrace that and give me your thoughts
or you have students come on and share
their opinions by now Harold is relevant
to their daily lives right content that
makes me think that's what you want to
post Instagram we're going to hear a lot
more from Felipe in one somewhere we're
going out more from some came on
Instagram picture based so you have a
picture with you could put a headline on
the picture and you use a bunch of hash
back to help give it exposure but I want
the picture that made me think and
snapchat the the latest darling and the
listening to come out is all about super
short videos five to ten second videos
really wrong cellphone stop recording
some videos and again you give your 10
second opinion on how Hamlin is relevant
to something happening in society right
now that's your job so I'm going to give
you five examples using real libraries
and what they're doing so first thing
you want to express yourself on this is
back to the zenith notice idea you want
to share your expertise you want to
share your opinions but doesn't only
have to be the librarian head it could
also be the people work at the library
people charges so from unicamp ain't so
list from the Toronto Public Library
that's where I'm from Toronto Canada and
they put a photo Sigmund Freud and they
say not everything Sigmund Freud hashtag
said still holds true today but he was
ready to go cats in time tonight with
cats is never wasted and a picture of a
cat who's got 24 retweets and 21 likes
and it's fun it doesn't always have to
be serious but that's the image a lot of
like libraries that is super serious
boring it can be fun have some fun with
it you guys have personalities express
it let it get up there this is my life I
yahoo
from the American Library Association
they created a youtube series on power
numbers hoists and this should be you
right this is the leader this is a todos
getting on camera sharing her opinions
bring you learn experts doing interviews
trying to impact change try to see
something meaningful and she has guests
coming on I'm talking about how to
empower diverse voices I love the seen
this kind of content coming out of
libraries this is my degree of Congress
they made a lesson plan for to kill a
mockingbird so he can get serious right
they take a picture they have a link to
the lesson plan so people can learn
about how to teach to kill a mockingbird
41-point weeks 30 through life we
provide value so let's express yourself
to answer their questions and this is
something i think that librarians aren't
actually good at right like people come
in and they ask you a question you
answer it that's what my murders are
fantastic at here's an example from
Santa Barbara City College Library we're
saying hey if you need help with finding
the proper citation or social system
research come check out our mobile
librarian and I tried to search and
serve to search for other examples I
couldn't find them this is sad because
the people who are visiting the library
are searching for knowledge they have
questions and they need answers to and
you as the guy are not providing a way
for the men ask questions apart from
coming into the library and the Q&A
doesn't only have to be around how to do
a citation how to find references right
if you're attached to university you
have students coming in and they're
ordinary how do i pick my nature my
parents want me to the county but i want
to go into psychology how do i think you
are the guide the knowledge what
resources can you give them what text
can be pulled from what videos have you
seen our stories can you tell them to
help them make that really important
decision I see that as your goal as a
librarian as the god so here's a couple
for the business world Gary Vaynerchuk
he's got to show a spare be enriching
the social media he's a good guy and
look back follow he does a show wants to
a couple times a week called the
askgaryvee show and he just sits at his
desk in extras five questions the
business and he gets thirty to seventy
thousand views on each video just came
to sit down next and she questions for
people who need help this could be i'd
love to see an ask a librarian series we
are giving them life knowledge to help
them along their path nexus involved the
crowd you have talented people around
who are part of the culture in the
faculty of your library that you could
pull inspiration from so here's a
netbook the museum where they did a
crowd cheering exhibition where if we're
saying hey we're going to put trending
stock up front we're going to do Will
Smith we're going to do star wars with
something else put out a poll on social
media ask them what they want to see
next right put on Twitter or Facebook
polar making YouTube video and ask them
in comments below get them involved and
what her the winner is you living a wire
going look at what you did with it right
they could star wars are going to come
in
library and see what you created so you
want to use your audience to help you
build something amazing I was talking
with a few nurse I'd Christian I she's
somewhere here I should share an example
of this museum that she follows on
twitter and they were looking for people
were seniors to share their story before
they passed on how this archive and she
volunteered her i want to say
grandfather grandfather and he didn't
interview what he felt honored and
treasured and he passed away last year
and now there's this living memory that
anytime she wants to hear her father her
grandfather start she can go to the
museum and listen to him that came
because of a Twitter post right and
she's following that museum because
they're not just posting our hours of
operation and promotional stuff they're
trying to involve the audience of things
so that that led to a powerful moment
between Fiona her grandfather in the
museum and she can take her kids their
grandkids they say hey this is this is
your family member and you want people
to have that emotional connection to
your library so get them involved in
things that that's deeply emotional
personal you can also have a fine with
it like picking what exams do you have
tuna the other benefit you have is a lot
of the people connected to your
libraries are really savvy with the
technology so here's an example from the
J withered mary library where they
create a makerspace and they involve the
students in making the videos so your
students come in filling it students who
are in the videos and for those of you
who are saying hey you know I don't
videos are
to do it you have you have the resources
you have the students get them involved
right rather got students in Camille at
the university would love to be able to
help make the project have your audience
help you make the content number four is
get personal I didn't know much about
mrs. Donnelly and it's kind of sad and
if you want to ask you why I accepted to
come here because I've been turning down
most speaking engagements and it was
mostly because of mrs. Donald because
she had a huge impact on my life and she
passed away last year and I didn't
really get to know her that well and she
never told me why should we came a
librarian and what I meant that her and
what her favorite books are in her story
and that's interesting and as a
libraries library want to tell your
story you want people to make an
emotional connection to you I love to
see you share what your favorite sources
of knowledge are and why you like them a
lot of people think that it's not about
me i want your mind it's not about me
it's about the people's for the library
what's what's the value on my story and
that's a big fallacy it's a big flaw and
Vicki because when you can make things
personal you get people to care if you
go to a more in library website and
click on the about us and there's born
pictured and a boring bio of everybody
nobody cares that's why people like the
YouTube stars because they're personal
now you don't have to be silly and
stupid but tell me a little deeper
something that it's not so incredibly
boring I was talking to skip last night
open is minus
story isn't one who say we'll see I dare
and he was telling me that he gets
invited to the speaking engagements and
he'll donate the speaking for you that
he gets to a local family in need not a
charity just a local trainability wants
to cop out this isn't tell me what he
bought it doesn't tell me organizations
and he doesn't broadcast it he just
doesn't because it feels it's the right
thing to do hope you don't mind tell the
story I told you got a talent you got to
tell people and it's not about I'm skip
and I'm the greatest guy and when I get
money way who robbed look at me it's
about inspiring other people if he made
a video that shared that story and a
thousand people watch that video and 100
people ten percent decide know what
that's a really google idea I want to do
something like that to the next time I /
speaking gig or the next computerized
sat on the next paycheck that I made I'm
going to give it to a local family in
need that can inspire 100 people and
instead of skip just helping one family
that was helping 100 families just by
telling that story we need inspiration I
need to tell the guys from egotistical
right you can tell the guys who are all
about themselves right Donald Trump will
get up in the stage and tell us all
about Donald chump but you can also tell
your story in a way that's cumple in a
way that is inspiring in a way that is
educating others and part of being a
leader is leading by example how are you
thinking by example if I can't see what
you're doing so time I want to know your
stories easing YGOTAS lead by example
tell me your story so here's an example
from the American Library Association
you know berwyn magbanua works there in
charge of programming obviously is a big
star Wars fan you know I know something
no this is not a boring picture on a
website where everyone is just smiling
that with the boats behind him you know
this is something personal and different
in Canada our largest bookstore in
chapters indigo was won by Heather
Reisman and when you walk in the first
thing you see our heather's picks and
she has her favorite books that I
recommended by her you don't like them
you get a refund read through it you
don't like a full refund you I would
love this unit lager you know give me
the director the library scraper kicks
give me people who work at the library
what if your favorite pics what are you
reading right now skipper it's a book at
night who told me imagine having the
last 30 books that skip is read as I
walk in and I get to know skip even
though I've never mentioned before as a
student coming in right I've never been
here before the head librarian or
director but I feel a little bit of a
personal connection share that it ties
to continue become much more than just a
citation a good point he was trending
conversations being a part of what's
happening right now type of technology
this is the application so this is the
texas libraries around martin luther
king day and holiday in the u.s. they
posted content related to martin luther
king when fair use was a big thing
happening the US all you see on a pole
went to Twitter and post it and exhibit
it's not a amazing exhibit but they're
doing something they printed up fires
they have some books and resources
around fairies week this one is my
favorite not just because it's from any
space mountain my favorite sport
i think is born when a live baseball the
Blue Jays have tried Blue Jays were in
the playoffs last year first time on 20
years as a huge deal for us and we're up
against the Kansas City Royals and
normally a custom in North America is
when two teams are fighting against each
other in the playoffs the mayors of the
two cities would bet each other my
team's gonna win no my kinsman Elaine
and whoever loses has to learn the
Jersey the shirt of the other team and
happens every year and it's kind of
boring not a part of the tradition now
what was interesting is that last year
during the playoffs the organization
that stole the show the organization
everybody was talking about was the
library hi what libraries are cool
what's happening in the Kansas City
Library went up against a Toronto
library and they had a boat battle on
Twitter and then we sent messages to
each other using books so this is after
trauma one kissing won the first two
games Toronto by the third game after
the third game between two this out
amazing John Blue Jays that brings us
around to look folks fine poetry and
they wrote the comeback bouquets blow up
the Royals come together and come
together was a hashtag that people are
using and look at 49 degree tweets 954
lights they were leaning like I'm not
just a part of the conversation leading
the conversation from a library it was
awesome and it got people to care again
about the toronto library when these
relevant things are happening everybody
is talking about in your city you want
to be at least a part of the
conversation i would love you to do
something creative and leave the
conversation but at least be a part of
the conversation so this happened in
october and this because written article
in our local paper about the big five
biggest fights that you're on
meeting with other cities in our history
and in the top five was this as a fact
of the library started it's still being
talked about and it's a library that led
the way and i love the scene that vision
coming from you guys as wealth of your
library in the mountain or city here's
an example from on wears on on areas i
spoke with our my youtube channel he has
a mobile bus that goes around this is
what it looks like and inside the boss
is not books on estate in the future
thank you no problem there's a box
inside the bus and some that books are
the enemy books are part of knowledge
we're not trying to write an e-book so
just part of the solution so teaches
kids how to make things and then go to
different events trying to help provide
access to knowledge so when they when
there's a concert happening go show up
with the concert and I'm 3d printed
wouldn't see knees with music from the
mains are playing a concert on it when
does the street festival they'll show up
to the street festival right where the
people are that's where you want to be
as a library so that's the awareness
sign express yourself answer the
questions involve the crowd get personal
and being part of turning conversations
you mix both of those together you put
taking pictures I think you're gonna get
the slides appreciated in a new to this
lens we are using these lines but it's
little bit slide mix that together and
you have a recipe for a library that I
hope people will talk about for
thousands of years one last point I want
to make on this is that you don't always
have to create your own audience I know
a lot of these folks and how can we
build
we need the other Facebook falling can
we get were wearing you can partner up
with others as well since a round which
had a exhibition partner of the Lady
Gaga Lady Gaga was a fan they made a
video together they're starting together
the guy who's growing on her social
channels Leah guidance Aquino social
media and tons of followers and that
gave a lot of attention awareness to
what the artist was doing you guys can
do the same there are people in your
community there are already people in
the student population if you're
connected to the University who are
already doing big things on social
munich mean I've even heard of that are
already big on each even earning are big
on vine and Instagram that they would
love the opportunity to give back to
their community their people who have
graduated from having gone to your
library right mrs. Donnelly asked me to
do something I would have done in the
heartbeat if that school came back and
asked me to be part of something they
were doing I would have gladly shared it
there are people who live in your city
who would be happy to part up with you
you know where your Madrid whoever's
from the library Madrid needs to find
Leo Messi and asking what is take the
book start what his favorite videos are
dissipated knowledge sources are and
then clearly exhibit around them and
have them share it on social you have
people connected to you who want to help
you just have to reach out so yes we
want to build their own networks up for
sure but you can also align yourself
with people who really have networks or
connected to you and feel warmly towards
you you would want to share the last
point quickly 10 min is that a lot of
people might be thinking well I love all
these ideas Evan those are great but we
don't have a budget to do that right we
can't afford to
sings I which is being cut by slide
saying I'm focused of being cut now he
wants to make all these investments do
they say I think it's an important
mindset shift in any leadership
situation is that you accept
responsibility that you never make
progress if you're just blaming with
other people right you blame the
government have enough fun you blame
Payton to not have enough funding for
you as long as you place the blame on
anybody else but yourself being i'm
going to make progress you blame your
director but who doesn't give you the
resources are the time to be able to do
it when i started in social media 0 I
had zero dollars I zero investment the
bank's didn't give me money the
government can give me money no biggie
any money i just started and you look at
the people who are being on social media
look at how they started it wasn't with
a bunch of funding it was from a
passionate person who wanted to get
started and when i launched a project i
try to involve latina my try to get
people interested in it and if i can't
get them i'll just start it i'll be the
army of one i will create it because i
want to create and it will be come into
existence and that's what you need to do
and i get that the resources are limited
and i get if you want to be up here
right here this vision vision for you
want to go and write god you're here and
you can't get here without the resources
and I get that and it's frustrating you
can get here you can do this on their
own you can go from here to here and
prove that it works and get some
momentum and then get more people behind
you to help you slowly rise up so JC
griffey is on here because he was recent
boated as the number
marian follow on twitter and he's a
librarian he has his own Twitter account
is not tweeting through the library soon
as own account and so if you're
frustrated stop blaming other people
start accepting responsibility and start
doing something failure is ok but try
and try and try and try again and once
you accept that responsibility you're
much more likely to succeed I don't know
people to be seeing libraries boring I
want my berries to be forgotten I don't
want my braces to go extinct I feel like
mrs. Donnelly who helped me so much when
I was younger and trying to figure out
what I wanted to do and solve my
problems who was so helpful to me when I
was younger could still be just as
helpful if not more helpful in today's
information overload society I want
libraries to be great again I want kids
to grow up and say I want to be library
I want your libraries to be remembered
for thousands of years because the
leadership and the vision that you
created may be here tonight or maybe
what's going to happen then next year I
want that for you I wanted to search
great libraries and your name shows up
consistently and you follow the recipes
that I changing those ten points you'll
get back I believe